아 가능하세요?
한번 해볼까?
이렇게 해가지고 이렇게 해서
나초리브레 같네요 영화
형 벌리면 돼
아니 벌리면 돼
아니 벌리면 돼 내가 도와줄게
됐어 됐어?
어 됐어
아 느낌 좋은데?
코 한번만 내릴게요
아 벌써 한 4살 젊어졌다
좋다 좋다
아 여러분 보세요
제가 이렇게
요!
아 진짜 도라인가?
야 쇠!
왜?
아 이거 하나 찍어야겠다
개웃기네
What's up 스웨이스
형
아니 왜 혼자 걸어?
결국에는 여러분 13년 만에
저희가 사귀어 오던 이 길로 왔네요
골목으로 가자
그러니까 나 진짜 너무 창피해
너무 나 벌거벗은 기분이야
형 근데
여기 있는 거 너무 싫다
근데 기분 이상하지 않았어?
왜?
방금 여기서 형이 아우 할 때?
아니야 아니야
좀 팔렸는데?
아 그래? 나 약간
조회수 위에서 했어요 여러분
나 약간 뭉클했는데?
뭉클했어?
아 진짜로?
원래 내일
일정이랑 월요일 일정 물어봤는데
다 촬영 있다 그래 가지고
연기?
내일 응
내일은
내일은 어디다? 신돌이
어 작품 많네
내일 모래는 문경 세제
그건 다른 거야?
어
두 개?
두 개 다
하나는 짧게 나온 거
하나는 조연이야
문경은 약간 사극 좀 아니야?
맞아
로맨틱 코미디 사극 나 하나 찍어
응?
아니 내가
내가 막 로맨스 하진 않아
그냥 한국 문학 이런 한복 아예 모르잖아 형
형 한복 입어봤어?
한복 입었어?
나 지금 그거 있어
이 시X하고 있다니까
ㅋㅋㅋㅋㅋㅋㅋㅋㅋㅋㅋㅋㅋㅋㅋㅋㅋ
이거 보여드리면 안 돼요 죄송해요
보여드리고 싶은데
자꾸 보면서 시X할 수도 있으니까
야 이거 되겠다 이거
이거 될 거 같아?
야 이거 웃긴데?
나 같지가 않아
나 사주 보러 갔었거든?
점?
거기서 딘딘 씨 채널이 잘 되려면
30대 남자 배우가 나와야 되는데
그래서 내가 변우석? 이러고 있었는데
댓글로 스윽이더라고
형 최근에 홍대 왔어?
아니
이 메인 스트리트 안 오지?
엄청 오래됐지?
오래됐어
나도 엄청 오랜만이야
근데 사람이 생각보다 많이 없어가지고
낮이라서
오늘 주말이잖아 날씨도 좋고
다 거기 가서 벚꽃 구경 갔지
왜 여기 있어? 맞죠?
여러분 지금 벚꽃이야
우리 맨날 여기 있었는데?
우리는 언제나 여기 있었지
야 옛날에 우리 때는 여기 오면
그냥 바글바글했어 사람 주말에
낮에도 그랬나?
어 낮에도
그리고 저녁 먹고 여기서 노는 거
썸네일 컷
와
일찍 와주셔서 감사해요 형
좀 더 늦게 왔어도 됐는데
우리끼리 막 수다 떨고 있었는데
못 털었어?
5분 늦었어 이 말 하는 거 봤어?
상하부탄 안 바꿔
형 5분 늦었어
대감동적인 게
나 여기서 그냥 담배 피우고 있었어
근데 갑자기 누가
촐라 이러면서 스윙스처럼 걷는 거야 저기서
어? 스윙스 혼자 걸어오고 있는 거야
우리 그때랑 똑같이
뭉클했어 나
옛날 추억 생각난다 이거
아 이 형 쌉티니까 아예 못하네
그래서 오늘 뭐 할 거냐면
우리가 그때 걸었던 그
삼거리 느낌 있죠
그 느낌으로 한 번 가볼 거야
아 나 지금 등장 자연스럽게 된 건가 그러면
어 그냥 한 거야
아이 그런 거 없어
어떻게 보면 우리보다 더 약간
연예인처럼 등장하기를 원하네
그런 거야
아 그냥 가는 거야 이대로 가보자
근데 나 화장실 좀 가야 되는데
생각해보면 그랬어
그때도 그냥 걷다가
어 화장실 가고 싶어
그럼 그냥 들어가서
어 안녕하세요
혹시 화장실 좀
근데 이제 다들 좀 조용하네
눈치 보면서 걷네
옛날에는 막
What's up 형
What's up you get
막 하면서
근데 지금은
아니 저쪽
그때는 신났지
나 여기 있을게 그러면
어
존나 뻔뻔해 어릴 때부터 저래요
늦어놓고 미안한 말 안 해
그러고 한단 말에 5분 늦었어
그러고 한단 말에 화장실 가야 돼
안녕 얘들아
안녕
에겐 스윙스 에겐 스윙스
딘딘 찾지 마요 난 에겐 스윙스야
지금 에겐 스윙스입니다 여러분 에겐 스윙스
딘딘 팔로우 하지 마세요
오면은 다른 말 할게요 제가
딘딘이랑 지금 한 반년 했나요?
1년 했나요?
반년?
어때요?
좀 성장 추이가 어때요 딘딘은?
이제 맨 처음 시작했을 때보다
구독자 수가 2배 됐어요
2배요?
좋다
나도 딘딘 나오고
한 만 명인가 누른 걸로 알고 있어요
딘딘님이 남 좋은 일만 하고 왔다고 그러던데
그냥 꺼져
개새부른 거 왜 나 불러
왜 불렀어 형이 그냥
너도 내가 필요해서 부른 거잖아
서로 등 긁어주니까
꼭 지랄을 해야 돼
저러면 더
여쭤봐도 돼?
너무 쨍까다
너무 쨍해
사람들 몰리지 마라
러비 스윙스
우리 왼쪽으로 좀 갈까?
왼쪽으로 가자
아 큰 길로?
큰 길로 가?
와 존나 창피하다 진짜
야 여기 다 바뀌었네
땅이 바뀌지
여기 왜 이렇게 임대가 많이 떴냐?
잘 안 되니까 옛날처럼
임대가?
요즘 막 안 북적북적거려?
안 북적거려
요즘 골고루 퍼졌어 세상이
그래?
여기도 핫하고 저기도 핫한 시대야
하긴
홍대, 성수, 명동
성수에 진짜 많더라고
요즘은 성수로 다 갔어
그럼 지금 쇼미 끝난 애들은 성수 가나?
그렇지
그렇지 않을까?
홍대보다는 성수가 훨씬 많을 것 같아
근데 우리는 클럽은 자주 안 갔어
그치 우리 여기 많이 갔지
어 여기
여우
광동
와 지금도 있구나
와 문 닫았네
와 씨
여기서 맨날 담배 피웠어
근데 일부러 여기를 담배 피우러
자주 나왔어
얼굴을 비췄어야 됐거든 왔다 갔다 하면서
난 근데 그때 나는 담배 안 피웠어
형 담배 안 피웠어
와 진짜 졸라 오랜만이다
여기랑 아마 저쪽으로 가면 그
매드홀릭?
매드홀릭 기억나?
매드홀릭 매드홀릭 매드홀릭
매드홀릭 있어
그리고 거기
그 브랜뉴바
브랜뉴바 여기 골목
와 씨
이렇게 셋이 홍대 걷는 것도
진짜 십몇 년 만인 거 같은데
그러니까 솔직히
절대 다시 안 할 짓이었는데
딘딘 채널 덕분에
나 지금 빨리 하고 싶어 너무 창피해
좀 천천히 걸어
너무 창피해서 미쳐버릴 것 같아
와 이 길 오랜만이다
어 떡볶이 집 없어졌다
조폭 떡볶이?
없어졌어?
1층
여기서 떡볶이 좀 먹고
그리고 광동으로 넘어갔어
하하하하하하
부르라
존나 툭하려는 짓이야
아 창피해 창피한데
부르라
하하하하하하
그럼 두 분이 막 부르라 하고 막 이럴 때
매드클라운 님은 어떻게 하셨어요?
이러고 있었어
저 그냥 가만히
이미지 챙겼어요
이때랑 똑같아 그때랑
동화대로 팔아?
아
그러니까
딘딘 네가 짱이라며
빨리 보여줘
안 헝그리한가 봐
아오
하하하하하
요기에 코쿤이 있었어 그치?
캐치라이트
형 우리 한
2008, 9, 10년
이때 여기서 공연 많이 했죠
캐치라이트에서
너는 했었을 거고
그러니까 여기 캐치라이트가 그런 데였잖아
그 언더그라운드에서 좀
먹어주는
플레이어들만 여기서 공연이 다 됐어
그리고 여기 오른쪽으로 꺾으면
내가 일했던
투앤에스라는 클럽이 있었어
아 너 클럽에서 일했어?
한 달 한 달
엑스레이트에 있는 데 있지
저기가 내가 일했던 클럽이야
투앤에스
그럼 내가 여기서 이제
아 뭐 10시 전까지 무료 입장이에요
이걸 했어
삐끼를
아니야 아니야
엠데믹 2주 2주 2주
놀이터
어?
뭐야?
어 진짜 놀이터 없어졌네
여기 왜 이래?
좀 충격적인데?
여기 가면 여기 추억의 놀이터가
신기하다
내가 여기서 쇼미더머니 3 사이퍼 찍었는데
진짜?
어
그리고 쇼미더머니 2차 거리 오디션 있었어
아 그쵸?
그걸 여기서 했어
아 진짜?
우리 여기 어디인가에 저 언더그라운드 공연 하나 있었는데 공연장
이쪽에?
여기 딱 이 건물인가 여긴가
또 없어졌지 뭐
난 여기 아이스크림 와플집 진짜 많이 먹었어
여기?
어
신기하다
놀이터가 없어졌어요 여러분
형
에
형도 부끄러움이 생긴 거야? 아니면 뭐야
어 생겼어 이제
나이 들면서?
옛날 아무것도 신경 안 썼는데
형은 지금 어때?
나? 나 별 생각 없는데?
ㅋㅋㅋㅋㅋㅋㅋㅋㅋㅋㅋㅋㅋㅋㅋㅋㅋㅋㅋㅋㅋ
이렇게 우리가 계속 걸어 다녔어 그냥 산책을
계속 그냥
그것만 해도 기분이 좋았던 시절이지
힐링 그게 힐링이었어 약간
지금으로 따지면 내가 마사지 받으러 가고 관리 받으러 가고 피부과 가고 이런 느낌처럼
그것만으로 나에게 힐링이 다 됐었어
그때 사람 많고 봐주면 그냥 기분 좋고 그랬잖아
근데 지금은 완전 정반대지 이제 이런데
돌아다니고 그러면 약간 숨 막히고 힘들지
근데 그게 웃겨 그치 왜 그런 걸까?
어 여기 아니야 커피숲 있어?
여기 여기 여기 여기
여기서 나 가사 많이 썼었어요
그냥
날좀 저희가 열려 그럼 저기 앉아 있는 거야
그럼 지나가 사람들이 막 지나가면 막
바중에 기다려?
아우!
뭐야
썹스윙스
브르르라
어 오오 안녕하세요
아 미치겠다
ㅋㅋㅋㅋㅋㅋㅋㅋㅋㅋㅋㅋㅋ
그때 당시에 세 분 인지도가 누가 제일 높았어요?
아 그런 거 말하지 마 쓸데없이
그때는 딘딘이가 제일 학고였고요
학고가 뭐냐 이씨
스윙스가 한 요 정도였고 제가 한 요 정도였던 것 같아
딘딘이 한 이쯤?
근데 문제는 그렇게 돼서
이렇게 딱 조인을 해야 될 때 이 둘이 움직이질 않아
내가 움직여
그리고 이제 내가 이렇게 판을 짜
그다음에 내가 이제
내가 볼 때 진행력이 그때 늘었어
내가 진행을 막 이렇게 해
그러면서 이제 사람들의 마음을 얻는 법을 그때 배웠지
여기 정도에선 또 할 수 있어
잠깐만 아우가 댐핑이 하나도 없잖아 지금
근데 형 옛날 아우랑 다르잖아
댐핑감이 하나도 없다고 지금
단전해서 안 오잖아
아우
이거 이게
됐어 이걸 원한 거야?
사람도 없으니까 내가 해봤다 왜
이 유니버스를 좀 잘 만들어가지고
퉁퉁이 비시리 노진구 해가지고
좀 막 여행도 다니고 이러면 좋지
일본 같은 데 가고
어 나쁘지 않지
되게 재밌겠다
뭐 여행사에서 가끔 들어와
운정여행으로 이렇게 가라고
아 그래? 좋지
그럼 가요 가요 우리
근데 거기서 내가 볼 때 또 싸워가지고 막
개새끼 니새끼 안 보내 말해 하고
오!
우와!
우와 너무 예쁘다
길 엄청 예쁘네
여기서 우정샷 하나 찍을래?
아 그 아
그게 뭐야?
그래
아 그래 찍어 찍어
형
안녕
하나 둘 셋
부르라
형
와 여기 길 올라오는 거 봤어?
던전 핸드래곤이야
뒤에 미팅 몇 시야?
솔직히 얘기해
나 여섯 시
아 그래?
왜 깝쳐
아 그래 내가 할게
형이 일찍
빨리 가려고 그러길래
미팅 또 촉박하려고 그래
촉박하게 잡아놨네 이러고 있어
아니야 찍을 건 다 찍어야지 뭐
어디서 미팅해?
저기 우리 동네에서
사업 미팅?
예
굉장히 얘기를 해도 요새 이제 우리는
그런 것들 얘기가 더 재밌고 와
그렇잖아
옛날에는 그냥 어디 갈까밖에 안 했어
맞아
제로 콜라 먹고
그러니까요 아 건강하다
예전이었으면 무정 맥주 때렸는데 그치?
뭐 뒤에 뭐 스케줄 상관없이 그냥 먹었지 뭐
그렇지 그리고 공연 가고
그러면 더 먹어야 돼
그러니까
더 있어 보이잖아
저 사실 술 졸라 먹고 왔어요
아 끝나고 같이 먹을 사람 먹어요 하고
그리고 공연하고 거기서 놀았어 늘
스토리에 올렸어 그리고
매드 클라우드 인디언 왔다고
지금 빨리 와가지고 스토리에 올렸다니까
그럼 진짜 왔어요 사람들이?
뭐 한 2명 왔겠지
그럼 그런 거 없으셨어요?
그러니까 누구 하나 잘 될 때 배 아프거나 부러웠거나
전혀
왜냐면 차이나게 누가 잘 된 게 없어서 그런 거 같아요
아니야
아니야?
나는 형
음원이 잘 되지도 않았고
공연이 막 내가 성황리 하지도 않았고
씬에서 막 나를 인정해주고 이런 분위기가 아니었잖아
내가 그렇게 막 노력도 안 했고
형들은 막 노래 내는 것마다 다 히트 치고
막 힙합 하면 막 스윙스 막 이러고
매드 클라우드 그때 차킷버스로 음원 1위 때리고 막
그러니까 나는 상대적으로 이들한테 되게 부러운 게 있었지
음악적으로 막
아 나도 음악 잘하고 싶은데 막 이런 게 있었는데
어쩔 수 없이 격차가 날 수밖에 없지
짬 차이가 장난 아니지
1년 랩 하는 사람이랑 우린 그때는
6, 7년, 8년 했을 때였고
이 형들은 이미 필드에 그냥 던져져도 싸울 수 있는 사람들이었고
나는 그게 아니었던 거지
그래서 나는 되게 둘을 이렇게 부러워했는데
그냥 열심히 했지 내 거를
이건 내가 잘하는 거니까 계속 했는데
뭐 어쨌든 영역이 달라진 것도 있긴 하지만
그래도 계속 잘 버텼지
근데 신기해 난 낫놈이에요
그러니까 셋 다 쇼미 같은 시즌 동기잖아요
동기인데 딘딘은 이런 음원 쪽 파워는 아직 약할 수밖에 없는데
노래가 없으니까 딱 쉽게 얘기해서
어느 날 보니까
박명수 형님이랑 막 예능을 찍고 있는 거야
한 6개월 정도밖에 안 됐는데
1년 뒤에는 막 유재석 형님 막 다 다
그러면서 와 얜 낫놈이다 딱 이 생각을 했어요
잘 풀렸어 그 시대에 잘 맞고
근데 내가 느끼는 건 뭐냐면
솔직히 진짜 잘 될 줄 몰랐어요
나도
진짜 생각도 못 했는데
근데 그건 있었어
저번에도 얘기했지만
어디 가서 안 꿀리는 그런 게 있었어
내가 지금 사람들이 나를 어떻게 보던 간에
안 꿀리는 그런 게 있었거든
그거를 계속 유지하면서 쭉 이렇게 행보를 이어오는 걸 보면서
되게 좀 뭔가 존경스럽다고 해야 되나?
그런 부분도 좀 있었어
좋은데?
아니 근데 난 이건 뭐야
형 노래 중에 브래비티를 둘이 같이 했어
기억나?
그 노래 재밌었지
근데 그게 되게 좋았어 나는 개인적으로 그 노래가
우리가 셋이 3인방이잖아
나는 왜 없지? 약간 이 생각을 했어
근데 지금 생각하면 거기에 내가 들어갈 수 있는 사람이 아니었어 사실
지금 또 뭐 하면 끼워줄?
이제 하지 이제
이제?
기사가 그래도 좀 더 나잖아 나 하면
그 가사가 나 아직도 기억나 그래비티
빌보드 케이팝 1등 찍고 뭐 뭐 찢어놨네 뭐
와 나도 기억 못 한 가사를 너가 기억 안 하네
형 빌보드 못 찍었어요?
빌보드 케이...
빌보드 케이팝 차트가 있어
근데 생각해봐 이 형은 그때 형 생각해보면
그런 거를 처음 해봤을 거 아니야
1위 막 이런 걸
그게 어디야
그래 어쨌든 최대한 하이브를 주고 싶은데
멜론 1위는 좀 자기야 볼 때 좀 짝짝한 거야
빌보드 케이팝 1등 이게 뭔가 되게 있어 보이잖아
맞네 있어 보이니까 맞네
내가 원래 쇼미더머니 1차 오디션 볼 때 쓰려고 했던 가사가 하나 있거든
나 아직도 기억나
내가 그때 일마레라는 그 레스토랑 알아요? 스파게티 파는?
나 기억난다
빵에 빵 이렇게 있는 그런 데 있어
내가 거기서 전역하자마자 엄마가 뭐 좀 해라 이래서
거기서 내가 알바를 한 달을 했어
거기다 쇼미더머니를 나간 거야
거기 주방장님이 나한테 이랬어
허치거리 하지 말고 이거 배워라 그냥
근데 내가 1차가 붙은 거야
내가 그러고 난 다음에 앞치마를 던지면서
저 이제 랩스타 할 거야 하면서 나왔거든
그래서 내가 그때 쓰려고 했던 가사가
파스타 투 랩스타
야 내가 파스타 투 랩스타 이런 거 쓰려고 그랬어
밑단에는 리얼했던 거네
심리얼이었지 형
나 그때 리얼 MC였어
리얼이지
근데 이제 인기 연예인인 한 명 하는 거 있잖아
PPL
아 그래 그래 그래
자 PPL
메딜에서 나온 세럼인데요
근데 그거 스템이라고
아뇨 아뇨 아뇨 아뇨
그때도 이 형 아종당할 때 우리 같이 했어
어 괜찮아 괜찮아
저 돈 안 받아도 돼요 도와주는 거
아 풍아 씨 하는 거야 서로 등 긁어줘
여기 컨톡이
형 지금 아셔야 되는데 형 뭐 번호 유출됐어요
막 이런 게 막 뚝뚝뚝뚝 오는 거 같은데
아 안 되겠다 하고 번호를 바꿨지
형 아종당 알아요?
아종당 보지
아종당이 이걸 해주려고
아종당이
맞아 이 새X야
너 지금 내 교물에 걸렸어
어 형 형은 내가 좀 나눠줄게
아 그래 고마워
같이 해도 돼요
고마워 고마워
메딜에서 나온 마데카소 세럼입니다
그래가지고 이게 이제 올리브영 이런 데서 판매 1위고
아이돌들 세럼 약간 이런 걸로 지금 유명해가지고
남자들도 쓰는 거야?
네 남자들
잠깐만 나 궁금한 게 있는데 세럼이 뭐야?
세럼이 이제 스킨 바르고 영양소들을 이제 모아놓은 앰플 같은 거라고 보면 돼요
그래서 스킨을 바르고 세럼을 바르고 그다음에 이제 크림을 바르는 거야
마데카소 사이드야 그래서 마데카소 있지
이거 우리 막 다치면 바르는 거
그런 성분들이 들어가 있어서 진정 이런 거에 굉장히 좋습니다
아 나 필요했어
근데 이거 한 한 달 정도를 사실 미리 썼어요
근데 나 지금 이거 아직도 내가 계속 쓰고 있어
왜?
피부가 반짝반짝해
손 좀 봐 손 좀 봐
아 형 이런데 있지?
왜 나 여기 타투 지우는 중
타투 지우는 중 이런 데다 좀 바르는 거야
그래 이렇게 하는 거야
그리고 남자들은 개인적으로 끈적한 걸 별로 안 좋아하잖아
맞아
근데 이거를 하고 나면 산뜻하죠 끈적하기보다는
그러네
그래서 흡수하고 나서 성분이 너무 무겁거나 이러면 매일 쓰기가 힘들어요 데일리로
그래서 막 일주일에 한 번 쓰는데 이거 같은 경우는 매일 써도 이제 좋다
나 같은 이제 막 40대가 된 그 남성들이 쓰는데
그 남성들이 쓰기 딱 좋은 제품이네
나눠준다니까 바로 아 딱 좋은 제품이야
산뜻하고 깔끔하고 거부감이 없어요
어우 벌써 좋아졌는데?
촉촉하잖아 아 진짜 촉촉
아 그런 거는 아저씨 그런 건 과대예요 과대
아 진짜 촉촉
저도 한 마디 할 게 진심으로 그냥 더 촉촉해졌어요 근데 그 찝찝함이 없어요 딱 그 느낌
저 앰플을 그대로 넣은 팩도 있어요
아 너무 좋네
요게 들어가 있는 팩이니까
훨씬 한 방에 효과를 보기가 좀 좋죠
그렇죠
그리고 여러분 아셔야 되는 게 팩하고 난 다음에는 꼭 흡수시킨 다음에 그냥 자지 말고 크림 발라야 돼
왜냐면 크림이 이거 성분들이 날아가는 걸 막아주는 거야
그러니까 이게 히트텍이면 패딩을 입는 게 크림인 거야
아
그런 식으로 하면 됩니다
어 한번 팔에 붙여보실래요 이거?
아 이거 팔에 붙여도 돼요?
아 뭐 아 얼굴에 붙이는 건데 지금
얼굴에 붙이는 게 아니에요?
얼굴에 붙여야 돼요?
얼굴은 좀 그렇지
아니 근데 중요한 미팅이 있다고 그랬으면
나 나 줘 나 얼굴에 붙여줄게
나 기꺼이 해줄게 그 XX야 어
아 가능하세요?
한번 해볼까?
아 형 오늘 미팅 성사되겠다
아 나 오늘 뭐 되겠는데 어 그냥 이렇게 해가지고 이렇게 해서
나쵸리브레 같네요 영화
형 벌리면 돼 아니 벌리면 돼 아니 벌리면 돼 내가 도와줄게
됐어 됐어?
아 느낌 좋은데?
또 한번만 내릴게요
아 벌써 한 4살 젊어졌다
좋다 좋다 여러분 예 보세요 예 제가 이렇게
메디힐 여러분 꼭 사용하세요 오늘 저같이 미팅 가는 사람한테 최고의 제품입니다
딘딘을 앞으로 많이 밀어주세요 좋습니다 강형도 물론이고
센서 시트에요
아 극세사 시트요? 이거 극세사 시트래요 여러분
근데 극세사가 잘 붙고 잘 안떨어져
잘 안떨어지고 저도 지금 저 XX 힙합공연 당사에서 아무 문제 없어
나 지금 이거 해도 돼? 그 머리에 이거 달고 하는
형님 감사합니다
아 아닙니다 아닙니다 아닙니다 잘 부탁드립니다
우리는 서로 빨아먹자
내가
야 우리 채널을 살리러 온 30대 대배우가 주인인 것 같아
대배우
네 제일 중요한 건 메디힐 오늘 저는 대배우지
하지만 메디힐에 대한 이야기는 결코 연기가 아닙니다 여러분
렛츠고
내가 과연 어떤 동생한테 이런 형이 될 수 있을까?
난 안될 것 같거든
나 해줄 수 있어
와 진짜 대박이다
딘딘을 위해서라면 첫 내 100만을 찍게 해줬잖아
이거는 메디힐 이거 수분 흔적 세럼이랑 KBO랑
아 KBO
어 여긴 어디야?
삼성
아 삼성 형 야구 좋아해?
야구 아니
형 야구 좋아해?
네
형 야구 좋아하잖아
어
형 어디죠 형 삼성 좋아하지 않아?
삼성 좋아하지
삼성 라이온즈잖아
삼성 대구야 대구
어 캐릭터 되게 귀엽다
아 형 이따 땀 닦고 그래요 햇빛도 많은데
공연할 때 이런 거 끼고 형 오늘 공연 갈 때 이거 껴가지고 딱 공연하다 좀 더울 때 이렇게 닦으면 되잖아
그치 그리고 나 같은 이제 40대 남성은 이게 관절들이 이게 가동고리가
아 나는 근데 그 옛날에 이승엽 마혜영 이때 있어
2023년 이때 야구를 좀 좋아했지 그거 말고는 사실 나는 지금은 야구를 내가 좋아할 팀을 찾고 있는 기간이긴 한데 왜냐하면 시구가 엄청 들어와
나는 내가 응원하지 않는 팀에 가서 시구를 하는 거는 좀 철칙이 어긋난다 해서 안 가고 있어
응원할 팀을 지금 고르고 있는 중이야?
고르고 있죠
아 세 분한테 만약에 같이 들어오면요?
야 웃기겠다 형이 포수하고
형이 형 포수 포수 그거야
그 다음에 형이 타자 이거 한 다음에
내가 시구하고 노진구 비시리 퉁퉁이 조합으로 해서 시구하면 또 가지
형 경기 보면서 응원하고 응원하면서 막 아우 하고 막 부르라 하고 막
부르라 하고
우리 콘텐츠 많은데?
그 쇼위더머니 2에서 그래도 가장 성공한 3인 아닐까 싶은데
요즘 좀 성적이 저조하다 승리 요정 필요하다 하시는 분들 우리가 갑니다 승리 괴물들이
아우
기사 다 때려받을게요 해가지고
형도 하나 있어야 돼 버튼처럼 딱 누르면 나오는 소리
스트라이크 좀 때려봐라
그래서 저희 퉁퉁이 비시리 노진구 패키지로 뭐 들어오면 다 할 수 있으니까
연락 주시면은 저희 콤보로 또 한번 해보도록 하겠습니다
도라에몽 도구 주머니를 하나 만들어 거기서 이제 상품들이 나오는 거지
어어어어어 오늘 MPP를 하면서 이렇게 제일 성물이야
퉁퉁이 비시리 노진구 여러분들과 함께 하겠습니다
안녕
아우
부르라
아 고마워
아니야 아니야
아 개웃기는 진짜
아 개좋아
아 근데 얼굴 진짜 형 진정돼요
아 그래
근데 이거 진짜로 좋아
어
나 이거 맨날 써